sometimes there's only one way to take
the temperature of a nation and that's
to get out there and stick your
metaphorical thermometer wherever you
can so that's exactly what I've been
doing
in the weeks leading up to Charles
coronation I left the Cozy confines of
the podcast studio and traveled the
length of the country all an attempt to
gauge the resilience of the monarchy's
popularity
the reason well with the death of
Charles mother and the end of the second
Elizabethan age it does feel like the
house of Windsor is at something of a
Crossroads or perhaps the edge of a
cliff
no one would argue that Charles
possesses even close to the affection
enjoyed by the late Queen and so there
is now a debate a genuine debate over
the family's relevance in the 21st
century and I went to listen
I'm Neil Patterson and this is this guy
News Daily
I take it you've come here to see
Charles today yes so what do you think
of the man I think he's doing a good job
it doesn't matter who he is it's the
fact that we have a monarch egg there's
a group over there called Republic and I
started my journey in York at the
Cathedral there called yorkminster in
fact Charles and Camilla arrived in
blazing Sunshine for the Monday Thursday
service
if you choose to be here he's the king
of his country and if you choose to be
here then that's what you've chosen to
be part of and if you don't like it
there are always options we live in a
free world I don't like football so I
don't go I'm going to be protesting out
the coronation in London on May 6th come
down and join us but of course not
everyone is a fan a small group of
protesters gathered with placards
reading not my king this is the
anti-monarchy group Republic their CEO
is Graham Smith well I've always been
opposed to the monarchy I remember I was
12 years old the year that Andrew and
Sarah Ferguson got married and I
objected to the idea of having to sit in
the classroom and watch the wedding and
as I got older it just made more sense
that this is you know not appropriate in
the Democratic Society Charles needs to
pay his inheritance tax he needs to stop
protecting his brother
a republic is about making Britain
governed better by having a accountable
independent head of state
oh
monarchy is about saying you're a
Spectators you stand over there waver us
foreign
public is about being participant saying
actually we're not going to have a
coronation we're on an election we're
not going to have a child's we want a
choice yet for a no even Grimm would
admit theirs is a minority view not that
public sentiment has been entirely
positive of late Meghan Markle arrived
and soon left the United Kingdom and the
family into which she'd married
scattering accusations of racism in her
wake
her husband Harry two pulled back the
curtain in his Memoir spare there can be
few who don't have an opinion either way
on the manner in which they were treated
by the fund by hani's father Lord Simon
Wooley founded operation black vote I
went to Cambridge to meet him I think
the first thing to say is hands up whose
family isn't slightly dysfunctional the
difference is is that there's it's
played out 24 7 for everyone to see
what I'd like to see Harry and Megan
back in the Royal fold 100 percent
the prospect of this family being center
stage with the King
unlocks so many opportunities
for a Multicultural Society I just hope
it works for them on a personal level
but for our nation I think it's a
win-win
for now a return let alone a
reproachment seems unlikely Harry butts
not Megan is attending the coronation as
all the world will soon see and on top
of those accusations of racism we have
been learning more of the Windsor's
links to slavery so with that in mind I
headed to Birmingham one of the
country's most diverse cities with more
than half the population from ethnic
minority backgrounds
watches the royal family mean to you if
anything don't really hold any relevance
to me at the end of the day because I
don't see anybody that's like me
um
at the end of the day there's nothing
that they do that really impacts my life
given the things that happen with
um Meghan Markle coming into the royal
family I think it just kind of shows
that the Divide is
very much real and that kind of like
traditional family life that the Royals
do have is not inclusive now those were
a couple of students from Birmingham
City University and I suppose that what
surprised me most was that they had such
a strong and clearly much thought about
positions on the Royals when I was their
age growing up in the Scottish Riviera
in the 80s well I just didn't really
think about them much at all
the University is also home to the first
black studies course in the UK its
founder candy Andrews is not long about
the role the royal family plays in a
country much more diverse than when
Elizabeth II came to the throne
on the other head of state right and
this is the state that treats us like
subjects it does not treat us like
citizens we just had the windward
Scandal where people have been deported
you can see pretty much every inequality
from education policing prisons health
is this is not a good country to grow up
in if you're black and the head of state
represents that it is entirely
unreasonable to justify this almost
exclusively white family and being the
representative not just of Britain but
of brought in other countries with
largely Beckham Brown of the
Commonwealth what that does psychically
is what that does emotionally is is to
put whiteness on a pedestal that's the
role so if you're serious about it you
have to say look we have to abandon this
rule Charles has suggested is that the
archives be opened up that the Royal
Family do start to be somewhat more open
about their links to slavery you scoff
there I don't I take it you don't think
too much of that I mean that's the
absolute bare minimum opening up the
archives in the 21st century for a start
we actually know quite a lot already
about the royal families our involvement
in slavery and a proper account would be
if it was actually serious he'd say well
actually let's try and account for how
much money and reparation we need to pay
the Royals certainly can't shed
themselves of that Colonial past though
some might suggest it better avoid
playing up to it as William and Kate did
and their disastrous trip to the
Caribbean and it is certainly hard to
Style Yourself the head of a modernizing
forward-looking institution when you
wear crowns and live in castles paid for
in part by the prophets of Empire
none of which is to say that Charles has
not had a positive material impact on
his kingdom
next stop Cornwall and the new build
town that he himself dreamed up Nan's
leaden
built on land owned by the duchy of
Cornwall I'll admits on first arrival
that the place struck me as slightly odd
with its perfect rows of pastel colored
houses it does feel a little like
stepping onto a film set but the
residents love it
Teresa Ferguson is part of the Nan's
leading Community Association and the
other Scottish voice you're about to
hear her friend Amanda Langley owns a
chocolate business in the town
I absolutely love it love living here
what we've got here is a Vibrant
Community there's lots of things going
on clearly you don't have to be a
loyalist you don't have to be a
monarchist to deliver in this part of
the world but but I wonder how you how
you perhaps think of Charles given you
know that this was a big project for him
it has been something that he and the
duchy have been pushing for for a very
long time well I've met him twice he's
interested in how his infrastructure is
actually coming to life and and what
people think about that he's very
passionate about that this place will be
around in 50 years time clearly I'm
gonna be cheeky right now and ask you do
you think the monarchy will be
personally I'd like to see it continue
and that's what I look at more than
innocent I don't judge someone on the
fact that they wear a crown and judge
them on who they are as individuals so
hopefully I'd like to see it carry on
because they've done a lot
the residents of Nan's leaden rightly
see the positive influence of the duchy
of Cornwall others well they have a
somewhat more nuanced take
so I got into a helicopter and headed
quite literally into the eye of the
storm
about the left the mainland Penzance in
fact and I've taken the 20-minute flight
34 miles to the Isles of Shelley which I
am reliably informed are beautiful in
pretty much anywhere though but I'm also
told that there the view of the duchy
and of Charles
that's a bit next
the silly Isles have been part of the
duchy of Cornwall estate since the 14th
century the duchy owns most of the
island and nearly a third of the
residential buildings there
it's all a bit futile really certainly
when you consider that residents pay
tithes in the form of ground rent and a
surcharge on travel and freight to and
from the islands the team and I arrived
just as a storm hit we actually ended up
trapped there for a couple of days that
gave us a really good chance to get to
grips with what some not all think of
the king
Allen
nice to see you Alan Davis for example
has lived in silly for decades he's a
member of Republic and fierce critic of
the duchy so if the duchy of Cornwall
owns these places how much money are
they making at this part of the world oh
well on Grand Rental we estimate they
take out close on a million pounds and
very little of that comes back into the
islands in terms of supporting the
islands so what then is your view
of what the duchy of Cornwall is doing
with these islands it's a cash cow
they're operating a feudal system
um and medieval fuel system and they're
just taking the cash out housing is a
big problem here over 200 properties
actually belong to the duchy they rent
them out which is fair enough but they
also rent our properties for Holiday
lets whereas we need teachers we need
care home assistance we need people to
operate in the hospital but it's not
just through leases that you know the
duchy is making its money it's making
its money off what every person who
whatever comes on all the freight that
comes on on over here and also everybody
who lands on the key in there they pay a
levy to the duchy and I think that we've
come to the point where
um royalty or monarchy is a feudal thing
and it needs to be abolished and the
Dutch you are actively working against
that don't want to see it but abolished
because it'll cut their income
softly spoken he may well be but there
was real anger on Allen's part about the
money taken from the Isles of silly
never to be spent there
yet he isn't clearly a spokesman for the
place so I went down the pub
[Music]
ahead of the coordination just asking
everyone what their thoughts are about
Charles about the royal family about the
coordination itself I mean are you going
to be celebrating it
not probably but I do working on old
people's homes so I mean a lot of that
is important to them there's a lot of
money that goes into them that could be
better spent elsewhere King Charles is
important to us he's a real advocate for
the natural world and protecting
Wildlife I don't think they should hold
quite as huge of a place I don't think
we should take them down or anything but
um you're not calling for a revolution
a lot less money poured into them
um because I don't think they quite
serve the purpose they may be used to
[Music]
welcome
in response to the issues raised in the
silly Isles the duchy says it takes its
role as stakeholder very seriously that
it plays a key role in helping to
deliver sustainable development and
communities and is facilitating a wide
range of opportunities for housing and
business
we eventually escaped the storm and just
made it back to the mainland and so I
find myself on another trip a journey
I've taken many many times although
according to my mother not often enough
the train from London to Scotland not
one part of the UK where polls always
suggests that people are slightly less
enamored with the Royals than elsewhere
the further you travel from the English
heartlands the more you'd expect support
for the monarchy to wane and Scotland
has always been significantly Less in
favor of the royal family than the rest
of the country another thing I love
about this journey is that it does
afford you time to think I'm sure the
queen felt exactly the same way she must
have made this journey 100 times
traveling from London to Edinburgh and
then on to Balmoral for our summer
holidays as I'm sitting here staring out
of the window I mean it'd be close to me
the queen famously had a huge amount of
affection for this place
I just wonder whether or not this place
has much affection for King Charles
I was four when we had the queen I'm not
anymore now we don't it's much more an
English thing than as a Scottish thing I
feel
do you feel like he's your king nope
light is mum
um
we'll watch you
I'd rather have him and some
presidential elected guy
I'm up to hearing politicians
as the country gained a new king
Scotland gained a new first Minister the
snp's Hamza Yusuf someone who's made
clear he would wish to bend the monarchy
if ever Scotland gained its independence
now this is fascinating to me there is
no a very real link between nationalism
and republicanism in a way that there
just wasn't when I was a boy it is
easily understood I suppose the prospect
of Independence affords the chance to
rethink the Constitutional Arrangement
the snpmp for Edinburgh is Tommy Shepard
is a prominent Republican voice
explain to me make the case if you can
for getting rid of the monarchy I mean
you're no big fan are you no I'm not I
mean I think it's a relic of pycon days
that has no place in a modern democratic
Constitution to be honest the question
is can we do better I think we can have
a head of state which is elected the
Monarch at the end of the day is a is a
a creature of the government of the day
and that's not a healthy separation of
powers in any constitutional Arrangement
and that's simply because you know they
are hereditary and no one's had a had a
say in choosing them the idea that the
royal family can persist for so many
people in this part of the world does at
least suggest to me that it that it
isn't necessarily all about the
Constitutional Arrangement that it is
about something more ephemeral I get
that there's a sort of stability and
certainty that comes from the idea of
the monarchy but you know we need to see
past that and people I think
increasingly understand it in the modern
ERA this really is a medieval fairy
story that ought to be left in the
history books
what's clear for my travels is that
those wishing and ends to the monarchy
well at the very least be waiting quite
some time the protest that we saw always
good-natured were literally drowned out
by Voices supporting the king
yet that the death of Queen Elizabeth
has sparked a conversation seems to be
equally incontrovertible
Charles's after all already are a king
this coronation with its rituals its
Priceless jewels and that invitation to
pledge our Allegiance well it's certain
to fuel the debates whether there will
be another of this scale or even another
at all is less so
like his mother Charles talks of a life
of service entirely understandably such
are the Privileges of being born into
the house of Windsor but for all that
there is a clear majority in favor of
the institution I suspect that the
number for whom that privilege sits
uneasily is growing and growing rapidly
he is the king after all doesn't he
deserve a coordination most monarchies
ditch these things a long time ago
Charles is already the king it doesn't
need this this is a pointless parade
designed for him to sort of say you know
look at me I'm King will he get it
absolutely right I hope so
is it a bit of a high wire act most
definitely
I think if you care about your people
then you feel Duty bound to say this is
my role
in 21st century Britain
and if I seize it then I can do good
things the calls for Colonial Nostalgia
is just as strong as they ever were and
that's the function of the royal family
so I actually think the this place in
society is very very well set for the
next 100 200 years
old tomorrow's daily I speak to Kathy
Lett a republican who's also friends
with some of the Royals including
Charles himself he was so prescient I
mean he was way ahead of his time on all
those environmental issues which I can
connect with him on that be time so you
know you can't help liking them I would
say Charles's charm is more disarming
than a un peacekeeping Force
in the meantime if you fancy watching
that documentary it's called my king my
country and you can find it on our
on-demand services including YouTube Sky
q and catch-up many thanks for listening
to this edition of The Sky News Daily
with menial Patterson this Edition was
produced by Annie Joyce our editor is
Philly bird
the coronation on Sky News followed the
king's procession and the service on TV
an ultra high definition and be part of
the day with coverage on the Sky News
app and YouTube channel also on TV and
online my king my country our
documentary on what the future could
hold for King Charles III follow the
coronation all weekend on Sky News
from the moment
front page news I need you all week all
the time oh God I'll just live inside
your trousers or something it'll be much
easier what are you gonna turn into a
pair of knickers in a scandal that
rocked the world you've got Prince
Charles saying he wants to be a tampon
inside Camilla humiliating proof of her
of Hell Camille Camille coped with the
nastiness and the Relentless abuse but
together Camilla and Charles's love
survived they've surmounted all of that
and they have a true love her reputation
repaired that turn around in perceptions
of her is remarkable given just what a
low base Charles and Camilla were on
Diana was calling Camilla a Rottweiler
and now to a new role beside the new
king this rain will depend for its
success in no small part on Camilla I'm
K Burley and from Sky News this is Queen
Camilla For the Love of Charles a new
podcast charting her roller coaster ride
to becoming Queen of the Commonwealth